hello golf now welcome to the heavy
spoiler show
my name is chris from 3c films here to
give you a good old american time
no more kevin spoilers stealing away all
the good american jobs he's done well
damn it if his accent isn't sexy though
that's some other bish so falcon in the
winter soldier is now halfway through
its season
and after episode three we're slowly
starting to see the pieces fall into
place
the series is obviously building towards
clarence from eight mile
battling out with the old man from up
for the position of america's ass
each episode improves on the last and i
think there's a lot to talk about in
this one
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the story easter eggs and
things you missed
whilst giving our theories on where
things could be going there's also been
some more toy leaks on the show
so make sure you stick around until the
end and definitely don't go over to 3c
films breakdown after this wait
don't go i said don't go anyway last
week we watched as sam finally came
face to face with bucky and a guy who
looks like what would happen if the
phrase white boy summer was a person
alongside him was battle star galactica
and we watched as the group took their
first
l to the apparent villains of the show
the flagshack the flag smashers
we ended on a big needle drop with bucky
and sam realizing that they'd have to go
to zemo
who was of course a name in the former's
redemption book
when we last saw him he was crywanking
over his wife's voicemail message
and arguably he's one of the best
villains in the mcu
when i first saw civil war i was a bit
meh on him
but over time i've come to appreciate
his plan and how he managed to tear the
avengers apart in a way that no one else
has
now we are going to be discussing his
comic book roots for the next part of
the video
but if you want to skip ahead then time
codes will be linked below
now baron helmet zemo to give him his
full name was the son of a master
scientist named heinrich
who aided germany during the second
world war heinrich raised his son to
worship the master race and because of
this he gained the impression that the
zemos should rule the entire world
after his father died helmut blamed
captain america
and the two developed a rivalry at one
point during their many battles
he fell into a vat of acid and became
horribly disfigured
and ended up donning a mask which has
now become part of his character design
over the years he's thrown down against
capping the avengers several times
which i'm sure you already know however
the reason i'm telling you this is
because he became a prominent member of
the thunderbolts
a group of anti-heroes in the marvel
universe originally founded by zemo
before the more modern version ended up
being created by general ross
they became somewhat of a shadowy
version of the avengers
that did the jobs they couldn't now
though we don't know this for definite
it does seem like they're going to be
formed in the mcu as there are several
characters in the upcoming projects that
will likely join their ranks
as we know general ross is due to
feature in black widow
and he's also rumored to appear in
she-hulk alongside this show
this it seems like he may be gathering
characters like zemo
taskmaster yelaina belova and maybe even
the abomination
in order to form the group the mcu's
zemo would make the perfect candidate
for this
as he's a master tactician that was a
prominent member of the sokovian armed
forces
zemo is a former colonel that was part
of the specialist team known as echo
scorpion
which were experts in firearms and their
fistos
who's fistos his fistos my fistos
mephisto now as for episode 3 this
zemocentric entry not only reintroduces
him
but it brings back sharon carter who he
learned last week was now an enemy of
the state since she broke the sokovian
accords
we open with somewhat of an infomercial
for the global repatriation council
or grc for short in episode 1 we
discovered that this council
managed resources for refugees brought
back by the blip that were displaced on
the planet
obviously a ton of things changed for
the people that disappeared during the
five years
and in far from home aunt may mentioned
how someone had moved into her apartment
this sort of thing obviously happened in
all aspects of the economy
including housing jobs marital status
and who the biggest youtuber is he used
to be me i swear
no now go to john walker in munich
entering the cafe owners headquarters
who last week we saw offered sanctuary
to the flag smashers
captain america is now working with the
police which juxtaposes how things were
in civil war
during that movie he and bucky went
toe-to-toe with those from bucharest
but here the image that he carries has
clearly been corrected
now cat went against them because he was
doing what was right
even though it broke the law here we see
walker threatening witnesses
and doing what's wrong whilst upholding
the law
showing how the two characters juxtapose
one another it's clear that the guy's a
snowflake and
respect and ego are a big thing for him
but i believe that these are actually
side effects of the treatment that he's
been going through
the last time he said he didn't possess
super strength we've clearly seen from
what he can do that he has abilities
normal people just don't possess
in the comics walker was given
superhuman abilities by the power broker
who gets name dropped a lot throughout
this episode and is likely the big bad
that we're building towards
i think that he's likely given walker
superhuman abilities
but this is being downplayed by the
government so that they can distance
themselves from processes like the super
soldier one
since bucky and the hulk have just
created such a bad reputation around it
now we learned that the power broker has
been getting scientists to work on the
formula
and if you want to see a bigger
breakdown on the character then check
out our episode 2 video after this
walker is extremely frustrated by the
flag smashes constantly escaping his
grasp
so he says you'll bet on someone with a
better hand which is when we cut to
berlin
here we see bucky and sam meeting a god
with justice on his top
and the rest of the guards all carry it
making me think that they should start
their own league
hashtag restore the snyder verse now
that just had droplet now last week
we learned that zemo was kept in cell
2187
which is actually the name of layers in
star wars and you hope
the password that the god gives is 6172
which relates to the publication number
of dark avengers dark rain
in this the dark avengers were brought
together by norman osborne
but the book also heavily featured the
thunderbolts tying back to our prior
theory
upon entering the cell we hear zemo's
chilling cello theme
and he starts to rattle off the mind
control words that he used on bucky
during civil war
here things are sort of flipped around
as in that bucky was in the cell while
sema was on the outside
and whereas he gained control in that
film here he's unable to
zemo says that there's still something
in there left of the winter soldier
and this is obviously a big thing that
bucky psyche must wrestle with
we've seen that he wants to make things
right but that he has to constantly
remind himself of the rules
especially the no killing one showing
that he might not trust himself when he
goes on autopilot
zemo knows they're desperate and with
eight super soldiers on the loose
it's clear that they have to use him in
civil war we discovered that he studied
the entire super soldier process
and was able to track down the hidden
winter soldier training facility
so he likely knows a lot of ins and outs
about it cut to sam and bucky
arguing over whether to free him in a
garage and this is a similar location to
the one we saw in civil war
when the perry grouped this is revealed
to be the zemo family lockup
and it's filled with classic cars some
of which featured in the first avenger
now sam brings up an interesting point
here by mentioning what zemo did in
civil war
as we know he killed king tachaka and
framed bucky
though the wakandans didn't blame the
latter they hold zemo accountable and
want to see him in prison
the episode ends on a big cliffhanger
that we'll discuss later in the video
but him being free causes a lot of
issues with their country
now we sort of jump back and forth
between this conversation and zemo's
cell
as we watch how bucky managed to break
him out during this we learn that zemo
is reading a book by machiavelli
now machiavelli is a character in
history that is very much proposed the
philosophy that lies to see in murder
are acceptable if one's trying to
achieve something that could benefit
society
this is very much where the phrase
necessary evil comes from
and zemo himself of course carried out
several machiavellian acts
as he murdered the innocent t'chaka in
order to put the avengers on a course to
where they would dissolve
machiavelli thought that public and
private morality were two separate
things
and these had to be almost opposites in
order to achieve greatness
it's clear that zemo sees this somewhat
reflected in superheroes in general
as he knows that they do things that
lead to the death of innocents
even though they have the reputations of
being protectors
now bucky two is following this
philosophy as he manipulates two
presidents into fighting
so that he can achieve his own goals in
sneaking zemo out
it's a great little easter egg that
shows how tactical bucky can be too
and he was of course trained in
espionage and defense strategies
at the garage zemo rendezvous is with
them and the group discussed how
breaking the law and doing what's wrong
in the eyes of it can be a necessary act
which ties this entire episode neatly
together thematically
zemo divulges that this whole set was
made when he hunted down hydra
in his efforts to stop them recreating
the super soldier serum
he says he intended to finish his work
and destroy all instances of it across
the globe
as it can lead to groups like the
avengers being formed this will no doubt
put him at odds with not only bucky
but also of course john walker if our
theories about him having this are
correct
now i love how they finally tie in his
origins with his comic book counterpart
and he reveals that his family were
royalty he also carries a coat with a
similar fur pattern to what is typically
used on his costume
and grabs his mask which becomes a cool
costume moment later on
i love watching zemo cracking jokes on
his private jet
and they slowly turn him into you know
more of a classic comic book villain
he too brings up nakajima who was of
course the father from episode one
now we have it confirmed here that steve
did give bucky this book
and it also contains the troubled man
recommendation by sam
which was given in the winter soldier
now zemo gives his point of view not
only on steve but icons in general
and how they are put on pedestals it's
something i've noticed recently in
politics
and pretty much every side seems to
ignore the bad things that their
favorite party leader does
and they completely overlook the flaws
because they believe the core message
if amplified these flaws can cause
serious issues and also make it so that
people can't be touched
and as we know absolute power corrupts
absolutely
zemo realizes that it's the people who
will suffer because of this
and his ideology becomes something that
i think elevates him above
a lot of the other villains in the mcu
he brings up the red skull
and from here they head to madrapur in
the marvel universe this fictional asian
island is modeled on singapore
and it's somewhere that wolverine often
frequented a haven for criminals
this place is separated into high town
and low town
both are as bad as each other but the
high town centers around more
white collar crimes whilst low town is
pretty much the petty ones
hightown manipulate those in low town so
that they can remain in power
and again it all ties back to
machiavelli the the writer of this one
must have been a big two-pack fan which
yeah the album bangs as well now jump to
a grc camp
to see carly playing football and i
definitely think moments like this
are shaping the flag smashers up to be
the good guys
it's difficult to paint someone out as a
villain when they're helping out the
poor
and watching their friends and family
die and i'm telling you yeah
they're going to be the goodies by the
end you just watch it
next we arrive in madrid and see the
trio of terror
going under new identities this includes
conrad mack
aka the smiling tiger from marvel comics
in the source material his mother and
father were part of a cult
and the pair raised him to be almost
feral under the monaco smiling tiger he
participated in several criminal
acts stole a quinjet and crashed this in
madrid
where he became a big player in
underworld crime we see a photo over the
character
who looks looks a lot like sam so is
possible that he will be popping up at
some point down the line hopefully
played by anthony mackie
with an escort they travel to lowtown
and head to the bronze monkey saloon
which is way more modern than its comic
book counterpart
sometimes called the brass monkey this
has seen several fights in it over the
years and it's pretty much the most
iceland cantina of the marvel universe
bucky's reputation precedes him and yet
as sam looking similar to tiger
they think that it's him it's hilarious
watching him having to swallow tiger's
favorite drink
which involves downing the internal
organs of a snake
and a one spores open up yeah that's
that's gonna be the first drink i order
now it's at this point
we get another mention of the power
broker we learned throughout the episode
that he's hunting the flag smashes
but the super soldier serum that they've
stolen from him this ties back to him
not only experimenting on people
but potentially also giving it to walker
who i'm telling you
was usaging all along now bucky pretends
to be under the command of zemo in order
to remain in character
and we hear his theme music thump away
as he goes wild on the locals
this gets them an audience with selby
who in the comics is a mutant capable of
interacting with any computer due to
being fluent in their language
they've changed the character up quite a
bit and it's unclear whether she
possesses
these abilities or not i kind of doubt
it and she seems more like an
information broker than anything else
now she gives the name dr wilfred nagel
who in the comics was part of project
rebirth
after the death of dr erskine he and his
men were tasked with recreating the
super soldier serum
and they carried out experiments on
black soldiers as we know isaiah bradley
went through this process
and they violated several human rights
laws it's going to be interesting to see
if they tie this into him or not as it
could have potentially been his father
that worked on it during the war
and this could link up with bradley i'm
not too sure on that but
either way we now know that the super
soldier serum being recreated
is the main driving force of the show
after sam gets a call from ryan aries
mom
the cover is blown and sharon carter
kills selby
which sets off a john wick-like bounty
throughout the entire town
this creates a big action scene with
bikes and all of a sudden
bucky can't do his super fast running
hey i noticed that yeah
but you should be running now sharon
carter arrives
and i was actually reading the ultimates
last night and remember that
in that bucky's daughter was called
sharon too hopefully they don't hook up
because
i don't know if i can take any more
incest involving this character at this
point
turns out she's been living in madrapue
since stealing the shield and sam's
wings
and they head to her place in high town
we discover that she's amassed a ton of
stolen artwork from museums
and swap them out with forgeries maybe
this is a nod to the fake shield being
put in the museum
as the real one was destroyed by thanos
in end game
but that's that's probably a reach that
let's be honest it's a reach isn't it
now sharon discusses the hypocrisy in
being a hero
and the episode very much tackles the
idea that the shield has ruined several
people's lives
sam grapples with whether he should have
destroyed the one ring though the one
shield
and he weighs up whether it's even worth
existing now the real gem at this party
is zemo dancing
and he not only destroyed the avengers
but also destroyed
every single person on the dance floor
with moves like that you can see how
he's the best villain in the mcu
and i want to see a dance off between
him and thanos to decide who's greater
shabao from here they head to the
shipyard and we see the classic madrapa
flag on one of the containers
in one they discover a secret lab with
nagel and gods descend on the place
which sharon ends up going atomic blonde
on it's an awesome fight scene
and inside the container we learn from
nagel that he was brought in by hydra
after the events of civil war
once they fell he joined the cia and
extracted blood from isaiah bradley
whilst he was a prisoner
this allowed him to recreate the super
soldier serum and he built an optimized
formula
that flew under the radar this is why
all of the flag smashes appear like
normal people
and it also explains why walker isn't as
built as chris evans
who's a hunk i'm telling you no nagel
was dusted and
once the project was abandoned he went
to work for the power broker
golly stole his formula and then
contacted him to help someone call
donya wish your girlfriend was a freak
like me who was the woman
we saw carly looking over dying of tb
due to the hygiene quality of the camps
she needed the serum to fight off the
disease zemo kills nagel and all hell
breaks loose when an
rpg is fired at the lab destroying all
of the scientists work
the scene from every action movie ever
happens and zemo puts his mask on
showing off the combat skills that he
learned in echo scorpion
buggy tells someone to pipe down and
zemo steals a classic car
sharon promises to return to the states
once they get her a pardon
and bucky refuses to move his seat
forward which is obviously a call back
to the car scene in civil war
at a grc supply depot we see carly
talking about how the life she was
promised was snapped away
by the people returning we get it
confirmed that they've taken the serum
and i captain obvious here but i'm
giving myself a tick tick for getting
that one fan theory right now these
refugees have been neglected by everyone
returning
and all they want are the opportunities
that were stolen from them
thus they simply view stealing as taking
back what's theirs
and due to their abilities they can
handle most problems with these
carly ends up murdering the security
guards at the outpost
and this will of course cause their
threat level to escalate
meaning that they will be hunted harder
than ever before
cap and battle star arrive at zemo's
prison and they decide to go off the
books to achieve their goals
this shows that cap is further drifting
into acting in shades of grey
which his predecessor of course got in
trouble for on zemo's chair we learned
that donya has died
and from here they changed course and
head to riga and latvia here zemo talks
about the sokovian memorial
which we know from the trailers he ends
up visiting
sensing that they're being followed
bucky finds a wakandan butt bead
and he heads to an alley where he comes
face to face with the chola's bodyguard
who we met in civil war
she shows up like what kind of [ __ ] is
this
and the nation is clearly angered over
zemo being free
now this could go one of two ways and
the first of that
being bucky explains the situation and
everyone
understands it the other option is that
it's war with wakanda baby
but i kind of feel like they will go
with the former and that zemo will be
put on a time limit
once everything's just kind of brought
out into the open
this means that the wakandans will allow
him to operate
but say that they want him brought in
once the mission is complete
but obviously we'll see whether he gets
away or not as
let's face it the dude has got those
killer moves
god damn okay so what did i think of the
episode as a whole
well yeah again i have to really marvel
at the production quality that disney
are bringing to this show
it really sets the bar high as far as
action scenes go
and everything in the series feels like
it's worthy of being on the big screen
just the way it's framed the varying
locations that we visit
and the sheer size and scale of it it
all feels like it could easily be placed
alongside the mcu movies and be part of
them
the acting is also great and i love the
often laid back
performance that maki gives which makes
him seem like someone who thinks before
speaking
this somber side makes him and sebastian
stan great to watch
and they really nail the complexities of
their characters even though they often
spend long moments in silence
that being said in regards to the series
as a whole
i do feel like some of the slower
moments hurt the pacing a bit on
re-watches
but i'm guessing that not many people
sit around watching these things over
and over like i do
it's a very minor nitpick of course i
just don't want to i just don't want to
show up every week like a shillionaire
in the review part of the video and say
you know it's amazing there's there's no
faults to it at all so
i'm sorry yeah i do have to discuss the
nitpicks now as we head into the latter
part of the season i really can't wait
to see how things develop
and this has got me hyped for what's
coming down the line but what exactly
can we expect
over the next couple of weeks well
before we get into that i just want to
give a huge thank you for watching up
until this point of the video
and if you're enjoying it then please
smash the thumbs up button also make
sure you subscribe for breakdowns on the
show every week
as well as amazon's invincible which you
should definitely watch if you haven't
already
now as for the leaks recently on the
subreddit marvel studios spoilers
an old post from last year was brought
up from atlanta filming
it detailed that hashtag falcon in the
winter soldier filmed at a former
courthouse turned museum
that would have a big character
appearing at it the post said
when you watch the show and your jaw
hits the floor
this is the spot where it happened i
can't wait for you to see who is in the
scene
remember to message when your mind
explodes now there are a number of
characters that this could be
and currently everyone on the internet
is running wild with theories
over who it is however we've been
working with a source close to marvel
and can exclusively reveal that this is
in fact
paul bettany again no no i've seen
people stating that it's either
wolverine or a member of the x-men
but after one division end up giving me
a soft one with that boner reveal
i am tempering my expectations has been
long said that the mutants are coming to
the mcu but whether that's in this show
or not
we don't know as of yet it does seem
kind of weird to introduce them in such
a grounded series
and personally i would have thought that
one division was the place to do it
however with rumors of omega red and the
x-men popping up
we just don't know i actually think that
it may be steve rogers aka chris
evans as has a lot of questions
surrounding where he is and what he's up
to
the setting of a museum makes sense as
well as the character is of course a
historical figure
and the shield itself was supposed to be
placed into one it could also be the
power broker or potentially even zola
who seems to have become the new
mephisto when it comes to the person
that everyone thinks will be in the show
i'm not saying that though i'm not
saying it's solo i refuse to go down
that band theory path again
now they could throw a real spanner in
the works by bringing scholar johansen
back
and it's going to be interesting to see
whether this is as mind-blowing as it's
hyped up to be
or if it's just click bait let me know
your theories below
and it also looks like we have another
action figure spoiler
that reveals the fate of one of the
characters i'm dropping a spoiler
warning here
just in case you don't want anything
ruined so bail out now
if you don't want to know cause because
it is a bit of a big reveal
okay so in addition to the sam wilson
ones from last week
we also have a black suit john walker
with the figure name us agent
as we've long been predicting the
character will become him when sam
eventually gets the mantle of captain
america
now this black and red suit aligns
highly with the comics and is pretty
much
what he's worn throughout his long and
rich history you may also notice that
he's missing the shield
and in the comics he does eventually get
a vibranium disc that he uses for his
protection
i think that the show is just going to
keep things simple and make it so that
there's only one
shield and that sam eventually ends up
taking it wyatt russell has recently
come out and said that he's down to
return after the show wraps up
and though he's the villain that
everyone loves to hate i would really
like to see him in this universe maybe
even as a potential thunderbolt member
hey
now anyway that wraps up the major new
tidbits that we have for the show
and it sounds like there's a lot coming
down the line that we can look forward
to
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and what you think is
going to be coming in the future
let me know below and as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize through on the 30th
of april in which we're giving away
three copies of zack snyder's justice
league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the entry
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
godzilla vs kong
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire plot of the
movie
talked about some of the easter eggs and
also the ending which has a couple of
cool little tidbits in it
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace